وفي منافسه تعتبر من اشرس المنافسات في
عالم التكنولوجيا هي بين اي واس واندرويد
تشغيل اللي بيعتبرون من اهم انظمه
الاستخدام على الهواتف المحموله بمختلف
انواعها واللي من وقت ما تم تاسيس
الاندرويد بدات المنافسه بين النظامين
ومقتصرت بس على الشركات فحتى الافراد
بتلاقي اللي معه ايفون ما بيعجبه نظام
الاندرويد وبيحط في عيب والعكس طبعا صحيح
اليوم يبدا انه هذه المنافسه او الحرب
الصامته ما زالت مستمره ففي معلومات
نشرتها صحيفه
الخوض ثلاث مواجهات جديده مع اندرويد اولى
المواجهات راح تكون عبر تطوير التطبيق
الخرائط الخاصه بابل اللي كانت طرحته في
2012 عيوب كثيره واخطاء والناس فضلت او
فضلت وقت خرائط اندرويد ثاني المواجهات هي
عمليات البحث كلنا بيلجا في عمليه البحث
لجوجل اللي بيعتبر محرك بحث افتراضي في
ابل ويبدا انه ابل قررت تزيح جوجل من
عمليات البحث على اجهزتها ولكن المعلومات
الجديده بتقول انه في شركه اسمها ابل
سيرتش هذه السيرج وادي الشركه مهمتها
تسهيل عمليات البحث وبتعمل على تطوير
ميزاتها في كل مره بيطلب فيها باستخدم او
بيطلب فيها مستخدم ابل اي مساعده من سري
او اي وقت بيعمل بحث على سبوت لايت اما
الموجه الثالثه بين النظامين ربما هي
الاقوى فهي النظام الاعلانات فالمعلومات
المتداوله لان الشركه بتعتزم بناء شبكه
اعلانيه جديده بتسمح بعرض الاعلانات
لمستخدم الايفون بشكل مختلف وبيتجاوز من
خلاله الطرف الثالث او الصياد